[Music]
we all have our favorite Disney
Princesses but which are each other's
favorites and which aren't
stick with us until the end to find out
the ultimate beef between two really
popular Disney Princesses don't forget
to hit that notification bell to never
miss another video now let's check out
which princesses have beef with each
other and why Ariel and Merida Ariel and
Merida couldn't be more different while
Ariel is much more innocent and naive
Merida sway is more determined and well
braved sure you can find some levels of
determination and bravery in Ariel but
the two of them would definitely clash
on their views of love after all let's
not forget that Merida is the first
Disney princess without the typical
storyline that every Disney princess
seems to have Ariel and Merida might
actually catch some beef Merida is all
about self-love but we have a feeling it
might take young Ariel a while to get
there these two would most definitely
clash of course they do also have some
things in common but we have a feeling
that wouldn't contribute to them getting
along after all can Ariel shoot a bow
and arrow can Merida even swim nope it's
two different worlds and we don't really
see a whole lot of middle ground for
these two Cinderella and Moana if
there's one thing we'd love to see is
old-school Disney Princesses trying to
mingle with new school of course we'll
get a glimpse in wreck-it Ralph too but
what we see Cinderella and Moana
together probably not because the two
really wouldn't have liked each other
Moana is also one of the few modern-day
princesses whose story doesn't focus on
finding a man meanwhile Cinderella has
been pretty much saved by the prince and
doesn't wanna even wear shoes we're
pretty sure she doesn't so what on earth
would these two even talk about their
lifestyles and their mindsets are
totally different for example get
Cinderella become a successful wayfinder
and Moana definitely isn't the type to
settle down in a castle with the prince
considering she's a voyager so what's
there to talk about really
we'd actually love to see these two
trying to hold a conversation but we
have a feeling Cinderella won't really
understand the lifestyle of the modern
day princess ands Moana most likely
wouldn't even care about Cinderella's
store
because let's be honest finding a prince
is the last thing on the girl's mind
Tiana and snow-white tiana showed quite
a few signs of a progressive and
hardworking Disney Princess that had a
slightly different plan for her destiny
well it still wasn't perfect but it was
definitely a lot better than Snow
White's if there is a Disney pair that
would get tired of each other after a
couple of seconds its Tiana and Snow
White considering our girls Snow is the
very first Disney Princess she's also
very much out of tune with Tiana's
slightly more modern world you can
actually see all Disney Princesses being
totally confused by Snow White in one of
the record Ralph's two trailers we have
a feeling tiana just wouldn't be able to
understand Snow White's personality and
Snow White would be happier if she got
to spend time with her dwarf buddies
they don't have a major beef just yet
but we feel it coming Jasmine and
Cinderella a lot of beef seems to be
between old school and new school
Princesses we just don't see them
getting along because they're based in
completely different eras and unless the
princesses are ready to settle some of
their differences friendship just won't
happen we feel like that's also a thing
with Jasmine and Cinderella a pet tiger
alone would scare the pumpkins out of
Cinderella but we also have to note just
how different and way more independent
Jasmine's mind is to Cinderella's let's
not forget that Jasmine basically thinks
all princesses are show-offs she barely
made an exception for a lot and Henry
pretty sure she wouldn't be on board
with Cinderella's Man Cinderella on the
other hand seems far too busy living her
ideal fairy tale did we already
mentioned that the pet tiger and the
flying carpet would totally freak
cinders out even the Disney fandom never
put them in the BFF circle the only time
we see these two paired together is when
they're ready to face vanellope in
wreck-it Ralph - Mulan and Snow White's
can you imagine these two ever we mean
ever getting along Mulan and Snow White
are so different from each other we
really don't feel they'd ever vibe
together we feel like Snow White would
get on with someone like Cinderella but
Mulan the fierce and independent
princess would definitely have a few
things to say about how Snow White
portrayed herself in her story Mulan is
definitely not a
Linda's dress and she's ready to take
down just about anyone
she's also way too fierce to be with
someone as gentle as innocent Snow White
don't get us wrong we love Snow White
and she definitely has her own qualities
but her lifestyle is just way different
we could already see that from the
record Ralph to trailer where Snow White
just randomly breaks out in song
everyone's just like WTF let's not
forget that Snow White definitely
wouldn't be on board with so much sword
fighting and violence in general it's
just not what she's about since no white
really isn't catching a break in this
video make sure to let us know who you
think she'd actually get along with
Pocahontas and Aurora we all know Mulan
and Pocahontas would be an interesting
pair for Pocahontas and Aurora now these
would be the princesses that would
definitely have a lot of beef with each
other first of all being asleep for most
of the storyline sucks on the other hand
we have Pocahontas who probably hasn't
shut an eye in quite a while
Plus Pocahontas is based on a real story
that's full of myths and interesting
history the real version of Aurora is
actually quite different from her Disney
portrayal and her story is much more
painful but that's for another video
either way the personalities of these
two just don't seem like they'd work
with one another we all know Pocahontas
is free spirited and headstrong Qala
rora is just way too gentle and innocent
they might be able to complement each
other but we have a feeling it just
won't last even the creators of
wreckit-ralph 2 seem to think so because
we weren't able to spot Pocahontas
anywhere near Aurora seriously go
rewatched the trailers and the slumber
party photo meanwhile Cinderella seems
to be the one that actually is friends
with Pocahontas since she's doing her
hair but that's totally fine Aurora can
definitely have other Disney princes
friends Aurora and Merida speaking of
Aurora there's another Disney princess
she definitely clash with and when we
say definitely we can safely say that
she did based on a single clip we don't
get to see Disney Princesses together
most of the time but wreck-it Ralph -
made that possible
but cholera surprised when we saw Aurora
not really appreciating what Merida had
to say sorry girl we know Scottish
accents aren't your thing just look at
the facial expressions she's making
she's
clearly over Merida's ramblings in the
words of Stephanie Tanner how rude
Aurora and Merida might not have a
direct beef but we're definitely taking
events sure Meredith accents might be
intense but come on these two aren't
even seen together and any other scenes
or photos so it's pretty safe to assume
that our predictions are correct it kind
of makes sense considering how different
they are from each other right did you
ever see that picture of all the
princesses pulling faces in front of the
camera we wouldn't be surprised for
warez just expressing her feelings about
Meredith just kidding just kidding but
let's be real these two would not get
along at all jasmine and Belle if you
never read a blog post on Jasmine versus
Belle you absolutely have to these two
always end up getting paired together
but it looks like they're always on
opposite sides Jasmine and Belle have a
lot in common but we feel like their
determination would prohibit them from
actually getting along we never see them
together in the wreck-it Ralph two
trailers so it's safe to assume they
really feel indifference towards each
other
but why bloggers from more power com
think that Belle is far too snobbish and
wants to live in an idyllic world far
away from everything else on the other
side we have Jasmine who's somewhat more
headstrong and not really ready to
settle down that fast it took her a
while to actually catch feelings Plus
jasmine explores the rest of the world
on a magic carpet and thoroughly enjoys
it while Belle prefers to stay at home
and see the world through books fans
have also noted that Jasmine fights the
strict world she lives in much more than
Belle does after all we just feel that
they really don't have anything in
common but is the beef so big that they
would never be seen together looks like
it at least according to the record
Ralph's trailers Snow White and Moana
speaking of entirely different worlds
here's another couple that would
probably ignore each other
Snow White and Moana are positioned way
too far away from each other when
vanellope enters the Disney Princess
room we later see them much closer in
the slumber party photo but we still
have a feeling they don't really like
each other these two just looks like
they're worlds apart Moana is one of the
most modern Disney Princesses yet with a
brand new and quite refreshing storyline
we
we know snow white's getting a lot of
flack in this video but we promise you
we can totally tell whose princesses
would actually be her best friends but
her in moaña complete opposites from the
actual design of their movies down to
personalities these two don't have
anything in common remember the moments
where snow white randomly sings in the
record Ralf - trailer she blocks Mona's
face and we're sure it's because Mona's
expression is even worse than meri does
you can't even see them together in the
group photo so it's safe to say the
friendship between these two is a
complete no-go but it's still not as bad
as our last Disney Princess couple Elsa
and Rapunzel of course we don't mean
couple in a good way because we all know
Elsa is throwing eyes at someone else in
the slumber party photo but Elsa and
Rapunzel we just don't see it happening
the beef between these two is all over
the Internet Elsa versus Rapunzel frozen
versus tangled which one's the best who
has a better fashion sense
they've been featured in so many battles
with so many different results we still
don't know the right answer but
wreckit-ralph too must have noticed the
beef because they decided to put them in
completely opposite corners although
both princesses are extremely modern
their personalities are still worlds
apart in one corner we have the
headstrong and reserved Elsa and in
together
there's the free-spirited and determined
Rapunzel
neither of these ladies is your typical
damsel in distress but because Elsa's so
reserved
there's no way Rapunzel would be able to
hold a conversation longer than five
minutes we do see Rapunzel getting along
more with Elsa's younger sister Anna but
we have a feeling Elsa would be sick of
their antics pretty quickly what do you
think who has major beef who doesn't
come let us know in the comments and
don't forget to show your love to Snow
White
that's it for our video thanks for
watching see you next time
[Music]